so if you clicked on this video or any
of my lore videos here on youtube it's
probably because you were confused about
something you saw or read while playing
elden ring and decided to search it up
so you could try and understand it and
if you're like me during your first
playthrough then you decided not to look
anything up nothing that could tell me
where i needed to go what i needed to do
and nothing that would explain the story
so basically i was obnoxiously confused
after my first playthrough so during my
second playthrough it was completely
dedicated to learning and understanding
everything i came across i read every
item description no matter if it was a
great rune or a tiny mushroom because
sometimes the smallest things bring out
the most detail in the most unlikely of
places however after about 350 hours of
playing this game since launch there are
still some things that i'm very
confused about when it comes to the lore
and i'm sure i could make several videos
after this one called 10 more things or
10 even more unexplainable things when
it comes to eldon rings lore and i'm
starting to get to a point where i think
the story was purposely designed to be
extremely confusing because having hard
evidence and facts doesn't lead to more
community discussion and exposure like
we're doing right now which only helps
grow the game and its influence on
youtube twitter reddit wherever people
have these discussions all of that helps
grow the game so i'm saying maybe george
rr martin and the writers from from
software made it purposely impossible to
understand the story so that we would
all have these discussions it helps grow
the game and i'm not trying to say that
i don't like the story i actually really
do enjoy it but sometimes i feel like
i'm a detective who's working around the
clock to try and solve a mystery case
and as soon as i think i'm getting close
or i have a clue and i'll make a video
feeling really good about it and then
i'll get a 15 paragraph comment
explaining something i've never even
heard of and i'll just question
everything i thought i knew about
something so what i'm saying is that
some things in this game just are not
fully explainable so here's just some of
those things i haven't been able to
understand also if you want to be a part
of these videos and discuss some
theories with me in my community follow
and message me on twitter and you can
also join our discord where we come up
with some pretty cool theories there as
well so let's get into this confusing
video
the first thing i'm confused with are
the recycled spirit bosses that we fight
starting with loretta while i understand
that loretta left the carrion royals in
order to help the albanorics find
salvation so that their race wouldn't be
completely destroyed what i don't
understand is why the spirit of loretta
is in the carrion manor because i find
loretta's story to make a lot of sense
except for this spirit boss the
albanorks were being slaughtered loretta
wanted to help them so she became a
member of nicholas haleg tree because it
was used as a hidden place of salvation
for the albanords that all makes sense
and it's a good story but why is there a
spirit summon of loretta here is this a
summon that ronnie placed herself to
guard the entrance of the three sisters
towers kind of like the summon ronnie
used when we fight against her mother
ranala or does loretta still want to be
a part of the carrion royals but also
wanted to help the albanorics so she
just left a spirit summon in this
location or is this just a filler boss
location so that the castle can actually
have a boss that we can fight within it
all of these could be the answer but to
me it just feels like filler it's the
carry and manner so they may have
thought
this manner is kind of dull with content
maybe let's just put a carrion royal
night boss here because it fits the
theme but then we see loretta again at
the haley tree and then i just got very
confused maybe she's attacking me here
because i unlocked the hidden path to
the hailik tree because i guess i did
open up the path to the halo tree and
the albanorks are no longer safe
potentially and then i guess that would
ask the major question as to why pretty
much everybody in the lands between and
their grandma attack you without even
thinking even though you're trying to
mend the elden ring which is what most
of the people in the lands between would
want but then we saw the flame of frenzy
ending that we can choose and it made a
lot more sense that everybody attacks us
on site they can't really trust the
tarnish to do what they want us to do
and then there's another spirit location
that i question as well which is moog
fighting us in the subterranean shunning
grounds i get that this is just a summon
and it isn't really moog but why would
he be guarding the entrance to the flame
of frenzy and the three fingers i did
hear an interesting theory that morgot
actually put mog's spirit summon here to
help guard the entrance because morgot
obviously wouldn't want us to become the
new lord of chaos which honestly that
theory makes the most sense to me
because morgot seals the entrance until
we defeat morgot himself but wouldn't
morgott have to actually be alive for
the summoning location he placed of moog
to actually work i guess not that's
super confusing to me maybe it's just a
fitting area for moog to be in since
moog and morgot were shackled in the
sewers from birth for being omens so
they likely know what's been going on
below the capital city more than anybody
else there's just nothing that actually
answers why moog would be here since he
seems to be completely preoccupied with
waking mikala up so that he can use him
to become his own elden lord within his
new dynasty under the outer god of the
formless mother but just like what
ronnie does with ranala it seems like
you can just make manifestations of
certain characters they don't actually
have to be alive or actually be there
for them to fight against you and also
when it comes to mogu trying to be the
consort to mikala wouldn't that just be
incest since moog and mikola are
technically half brothers or are they
just brothers since ratagon america are
the same person which we'll get into
later because i'm getting carried away
here and confusing myself just talking
about this so let's just move on to some
more confusing spirit locations like why
is godfrey's golden spirit here before
we face morgot is this just another
spirit summon location that moore got
placed to stop our path to the earth
tree is this the greater wills
manifestation of godfrey in his perfect
elden lord form or is this really
godfrey fighting us from another land
far away but he isn't physically in the
lands between yet and he's trying to
serve the greater will even though he
was banished from the lands between for
technically being too good at his job
and defeating all of their enemies which
is another thing i can get into that
queen america took away godfrey's
guidance of grace because they had
nobody else to fight and then they
banished him and his army to battle in a
far away land like the badlands in hopes
that they would get their grace back if
they did that all in my opinion has to
do with america's big plan that i
already made a video on but this summon
location of godfrey yet again just feels
like filler and doesn't make a ton of
sense and speaking of filler i'll just
talk about this really quickly but why
is there a snail
summoning the godskins in the
mountaintops of the giants like at this
point we have already fought these guys
several other times in many other places
but just the fact that the snail is
summoning them in this random cave in
the mountaintops just feels like
miyazaki really liked the godskin's
music and wanted us to hear it over and
over again which by the way the music
for this fight absolutely slaps so i'm
not complaining about that but it still
doesn't stop my confusion of why we
fight them in this area and honestly so
many other areas like when i kill a boss
in all of the from software games i like
to have that feeling that i defeated a
great foe and won't have to deal with
them ever again after i do beat them it
makes me feel like i actually won while
elden ring just says [ __ ] you you're
going to have to beat some of these
bosses multiple times i guess it kept me
on my toes but it still was super
confusing in regards to the lore so
after this one i think i'm done with
being confused about the spirits in
reused bosses it just feels like a lot
of filler to me but let's move on to the
mausoleums i get that these giant
mausoleums are connected to the demigods
because there's a lot of good evidence
that supports this the greatest piece of
evidence we can gather is from the
eclipse crest heater shield which reads
the sun in eclipse is said to be the
symbol of the wandering mausoleum where
the soulless demigods slumber there's
also a ghost outside of the church of
pilgrimage that says the mausoleum prows
cradling the soulless demigod america
queen eternal he is your unwanted child
so immediately when i hear the word
solas and being the child of america i
think of godwin whose soul was killed in
the night of black knives if this were
true it would make much more sense that
godwin was purposely sacrificed by
america and ronnie for their bigger
secret plot in the night of black knives
if he was her unwanted child but then
there's another ghost in castle's soul
that says lord mikala forgive me the sun
has not been swallowed our prayers were
lacking your comrade remains soulless i
will never set my eyes upon it now your
divine hail tree so now of course i'm
just more confused like what do they
mean by soulless do they mean this
literally like godwin not having a soul
and just being a husk of a body or do
they mean it as another word for evil
but what can be referred to as evil in
the lands between nobody knows since
everything and everyone is trying to
kill us except for our cool turtle dog
pope who i like to believe commands the
mausoleums as a place for the demigods
to repent their sins and what evidence
do i have for this absolutely nothing
besides that the mausoleums look like a
turtle or i'm sorry you guys like to
call them dogs we are really all out
here trying to confuse ourselves aren't
we to go along with this
what the hell are the evergales i
understand how they work as prisons for
people who are seen as traitors in some
way but then we get to the consecrated
snow fields and an entire town of by the
way absolute bullshittery is trapped
inside of an evergale so i guess that
means you can trap anything inside an
ebergale also to go along with this who
is god of free gotta fro gotta froy go
go to fra no idea how to pronounce his
name but why does he look exactly like
godric and from some comments i've
received you guys are telling me that
god of god of freud however you say his
name is a completely different person
than godric even though they look
exactly alike and i've heard some
theories that god of roy was supposed to
look different from godric but from
software supposedly ran out of money and
just decided to use the same model as
godric to save time change his name and
they just called it a day i find it hard
to believe that they just ran out of
money but the game did do better than
they originally predicted so i guess
that's possible either way that just
makes me extremely confused like the
evergales and god of roy really gave me
a headache when i tried to find more
information on them but all i know right
now is that don't let blide out of eg's
evergale don't do it unless you want to
cry yourself to sleep tonight also can
we talk about who the [ __ ] is rena we
can read from the snow witch set that
reads once born by the snowy crone who
the young ronnie encountered deep in the
woods she was a witch and well versed in
cold sorceries it is said that the doll
that houses ronnie's soul was modeled
after her that old witch was ronnie's
secret mentor now honestly since the
game came out and we learned this we
have all just been assuming that rena is
the name of ronnie's mentor since she
inherits a doll that looks like her
ronnie uses her name as an alias at one
point and she has her own tower next to
ronnie's but i've received some comments
saying that rena is just short for
ranala and that her mother was actually
her mentor now this is my least favorite
theory but i guess we can't completely
discredit that since we don't know who
rena is we're all just guessing and
honestly sometimes i feel like i'm just
guessing with 90 of the lore throughout
the entire game it's very frustrating
but fun all at the same time next thing
i want to talk about is do we really
know if this is mikala i know moog calls
him mikola in this cut scene but i'm
still not 100 sold because we can
clearly see that the cocoon we find in
moguin's palace was taken from this spot
in the haley tree and i've heard some
theories that mikala is this body form
we can see that have formed in the roots
of the boss room now i don't think this
is actually true like this probably is
mykola in this cocoon in mogwin's palace
but why is his cocoon resting on a
pelvic bone was he being rebirthed by
this motherly figure of the helic tree
is that why his body looks to be kind of
malformed inside the cocoon because in
my opinion he looks very different from
the opening cut scene where mikola has
flowing blonde hair he seems much
smaller than moog but then when we see
him in moguin's palace he's clearly much
larger than the cutscene and all of his
hair is just gone to point out just a
couple of things i noticed and finally
the last thing i'm confused about and
i'm sure all of you saw this one coming
is how the f are ratagon in america the
same person and how at the same time and
they have children whenever i'm
explaining the family line aspect of
elden ring in my videos i always have to
randomly mention that america and
radagon are the same person just in case
someone out there doesn't know that like
i can go with the fact that they're the
same person i started accepting these
things when i started talking to a pope
dog in a giant pot but trying to think
of how the same person can [ __ ]
themselves so hard that they actually
get pregnant and have children is quite
confusing but i can't be thinking that
basic right we haven't seen how anything
comes to life in this world everything
could be borne by eggs for all we know
it's not the conventional birthing
process that we know of in our world
like you can have a mother and a father
but that doesn't mean only the mother in
the lands between has to birth the child
and that they need to do the dirty deed
to actually reproduce which thinking
this way just confuses me even more than
i already was but i like to tell myself
these things that really make no sense
in my brain to try and understand how
other things might happen in the world
of elden ring and maybe there are
answers to all of these questions that i
just haven't pieced together at this
point and most of the time you guys do
send me some really interesting theories
that you make on your own but then i'll
find a clue that completely discredits
my own theory and that theory that you
sent me it's all just very confusing
probably like the format of this video
which has somewhat been a frustrating
mess of information and while i would
love to be the dictionary of all things
eldon ring for you guys i'm just a human
being like all of you who's obsessed
with figuring out the story of this
amazing game however i am starting to
come to the realization that it might
just not be possible to piece all of the
information together to come up with a
cohesive understandable story it's
complicated but i love the game so much
that i don't care about the frustrations
i have with certain aspects of the lore
it's always fun to speculate so let me
know what you guys think if you want
early access to these videos along with
some other really cool benefits join our
patreon along with these cool people
like pascal john david arthea hunter
elliott and blacklisted i will always
shout you guys out in every video i make
have a great rest of your day take care
[Music]
you